James Corden is taking the Late Late
Show to his home country of England he
shot a special open for this week's
episodes which will be hosting from
London starting tonight Corden and his
team spent the last few days on the city
streets shooting skits including a Mary
Poppins crosswalk musical Jonathan
Vigliotti tagged along with cording to
give us a special behind-the-scenes look
as comedian James Corden wrote a
double-decker bus through the streets of
London last week he received a warm
hometown welcome which kid and wish was
to come to London no way James how are
you what's your name Brian how nice to
see you
Jordan was shooting the opening sequence
of The Late Late Show and bandleader
Reggie Watts was along for the ride
photo - Gordon found his fame on these
streets
now just poke out your tongue and
photobombing a couple taking engagement
photos was a welcome surprise
enjoy your stage photos are really
natural really natural is how wedding
you not like this all the time it capped
off a long day that began with a
conversation atop his bus welcome home
how has it been to be back on your home
turf it's really nice the whole thing's
been
just a real dream of mine really you
have this amazing homecoming lined up
for you
you've got Tom Cruise we have in the
coal cumin and Kit Harington and
brand-new carpool karaoke with Ed
Sheeran 10 million YouTube subscribers
in April which is unbelievable hundreds
of millions of views on carpool karaoke
what is it what's the secret
attending there's a secret it's very
difficult if you make a show that starts
at 12:30 7:00 in the morning to find how
you'll make that impact we know that we
have to find our audience and our
relevance wherever we can and the great
thing about the internet is it's not
predicated by any big lead in or new
story this is who our show is and this
is the show we want to make and we want
to provide to you some light and levity
at the end of every day that light and
levity have made court in a bonafide
late-night star
but he's also taken a serious approach
to the recent terror attacks in his home
country and I'm telling you a more
tight-knit group of people you will be
hard-pressed to find Gordon and his team
have had to rethink tonight's episode in
light of the most recent attack in
London politics has also been fertile
ground for comedy in other Trump news in
an interview with The Economist starting
today Donald Trump said I think we
balanced it as well as we can I'm always
very conscious in the fact I didn't grow
up in America that I'm from a tiny town
called High Wycombe which is about 40
minutes that way and so it would be I
think it would be foolish to feel like I
can speak to parts of America that I've
never even been to it's like did a great
video when you were travelling here to
London where you showed the process how
easy it was for you this was just after
the proposed Muslim ban yeah look I
don't consider our show to be not
political I just don't think we can
dedicate our whole show to that I don't
think that's where my strengths lie I'm
a 38 year old British guy who's lived in
America for 27 months when the president
proposed that ban I think everybody in
our office quite hard and we thought
well freedom of travel should be simple
for every legal immigrant not just the
white and Christian ones and that's what
we wanted to say so we never shy away
from it which is conscious of the fact
that I don't know that we've earned the
right to talk to people that if an
American comedian came over here and
started talking to me about the general
election about what do you know up here
how do you know what people how do you
know how people are struggling in
Liverpool you know I
on the streets of London he was feeling
the love leaving no doubt he can bring
it home for CBS this morning
Jonathan Vigliotti London
he is really beloved in England they say
you walk with him it's like being in a
parade it's interesting though because
he had planned that trip long before he
always shows a lot of common sense well
he does he's very funny guy nice guy too
you can watch The Late Late Show with
James Corden in London tonight through
Thursday at 12:37 you heard him say that
11:37 central that's right after The
Late Show with Stephen Colbert right
here on CBS we'll be right back